تويتر تحت قياده ماسك حاله انهيار ام كما
يقال انها بدايه جديده بامكانيات اكثر
وشكل جديد واتساع لحريه الراي والتعبير
لكن مع حاله التخبط هناك منصات تنتظر
الفرصه لتحل مكانه ما استدوم اصبحت تحقق
مشيه متسارعه للتجاوز المليون المشترك
وذلك حسب مؤسسها الالماني ليجن روشكو
بواقي 490,000 مستخدم جديد منذ استحواذي
ماسك على تويتر ايضا اشياء اخرى تثير
الفضول بينها شبكات كونتر
سوشيال التي اطلقها التي اطلقها ترامب
تقدم نفسها في الاساس على انها بدائل عن
تويتر لكن تبدو منصه برو سكاي بديلا قويا
تويتر وهي التي انشاها احد مؤسسات تويتر
عام 2022
واعلن اكثر من 30,000 شخص على قائمه
الانتظار
كان نفسه على انه تطبيق تواصل اجتماعي لا
مركزي يتيح للمستخدم التحكم في خوارزمياته
والسيطره على بياناتهم بشكل كامل